there's going to be various political
stances arise in relation to all of this
stuff
for instance one faction will say that
nothing at all is wrong this is I think
what we see going on now that there's a
kind of collusion by governments and
institutions to manage apocalyptic
awareness and to say well you don't need
to worry about the fact that ozone is
disappearing from the atmosphere because
by 2000 we will have a 7% reduction in
output of CFCs and by 2050 we're
planning a further 7 per standard and
anything no no these are crazy people
obviously the you know there's a lot of
arranging the deck chairs on the Titanic
and but I think eventually that
fluctuations as the fluctuations become
more violent they will burst through and
pollute and political dialogues will
start on various fronts it's hard to say
where it will come for instance you know
historians of the of the breakup of the
Soviet Union can reasonably argue that
what actually the hole in the dike there
was the Chernobyl explosion and that
actually set off a series of thoughts of
awareness people's minds changed it was
like a psychedelic drug this radiation
spreading through Soviet society because
they realized my god you know this was a
power plant it was at ground level it
wasn't even a designed explosion an
eighth day
after it happened above Auckland New
Zealand you could sample the the
radiation in the air so there was a
whole crisis of faith in the command
economy in everything and this could
happen something this will happen the
one thing you can be sure of is that the
90s will be shaped by the unexpected
could be anything a hot day in August in
Mexico City and a minyan people die when
finally all of these toxic levels come
together as they potentially could or it
could be a nuclear failure or it could
be an assassination or it could be the
outbreak of a synthetic disease or
anything you know and what this will
bring home to people is that the
metastable nature of society is
beginning to break down that the
shockwaves of the future are building up
and what you you know in in engineering
an airfoil engineers have to take
account of what is called q forces
vibration if you don't design the
airfoil correctly as you approach the
speed of sound the wings of the airplane
will be torn off and so you have to
redesign the airplane to move through
this barrier what we have to do is
redesign the cultural airfoil so that we
slip what what you mean that it
shouldn't support wrecking the third
world now see I think that that kind of
thing is is like talking about closing
air bases near Sacramento and whether
Western civilization can survive the
shock of these this loss of jobs we're
returning into an information society
and managers are trying to meet the
crisis but if my faith rested with human
managers I'd be frantic
the main thing is that the design
process is being imposed by nature
itself just in the way that a supersonic
aircraft has its design imposed by
nature itself the nature of the medium
is dictating the shape of the society
that is coming into being the main thing
is to try to make this through with as
little bloodshed and hysteria as
possible it's very hard call
I mean looking at something like Bosnia
you know the impulse to use f8 teams to
correct the problem is very great and
yet you know in the past this has not
brought joy and Thanksgiving where it
was used and also the hubris of thinking
that you're you know your job is to
separate these people on the other hand
we can't have people running around
trading nuclear weapons in the red light
district of Frankfurt and which is going
on this is actually going on there is a
great potential for chaos on the
Eurasian landmass right now how should
that be managed and you know a lot of
people have nuclear weapons who have no
business having nuclear weapons I think
we need to disarm from the top that's a
political agenda and what one thing that
has to be understood is that what is
going on is a process of fragmentation
and that is what is supposed to happen
at this cultural stage I think McLuhan
talked about what he called electronic
feudalism wherever fragmentation is
resisted violence and war and horror
will break out for instance you know
five years ago there was great
anticipation of the federal Europe that
ran against the current of dissolution
and now we see there won't be any
federal Europe I mean there'll be
something on paper in Brussels to keep
the diplomats shuttling back and forth
and there will be no unified psychology
they're going tribal the great political
force shaping the 90s on one level is
ethnicity and turf battles as these huge
ideologies withdraw their Imperium all
these local satrapies and warlords begin
to exercise their historical claims
Islam is set to make enormous gains
this has to be accepted in the West it
shouldn't be resisted the historical
momentum is too great and you know it's
700 million people and it represents the
only reservoir of tradition of
significance left on the planet in terms
of a political agenda I mean it's it's
pretty clear the psychedelic thing
speaks to freedom and so you can shine
that on a number of issues of women's
rights abortion legalization of drugs
but but I don't but not absolute
libertarian anarchy because I don't
think we want to get rid of the food and
drug administration we may want to
execute the top echelon and replace it
but the concept of you know I mean I've
lived in a country without a pure drug
act and it's a nightmare in India you
can't buy pepper without being afraid
that it's been contaminated with lead
flakes to make it way more when you buy
it in the market
well but we've all had none of us ever
had the psychedelic experience in a safe
environment I mean we could we come out
of the nightmare ages
I took psychedelic drugs under the aegis
of Richard Milhous Mason
I mean I've stared the archetypal danger
in the face
I took psychedelics under Indira Gandhi
that was the bottom line is that we're
in the roller coaster the little pipe
has now been dropped into your lap
please do not stand up scream if you
want hang on and and we'll come through
it but we have to reassure people in the
way you reassure people is by getting
them to transcend the systems which are
spreading the anxiety I mean if you're a
fascist if you're a capitalist if you
have some vested interest in the system
then you're going to be sweating blood
and you have to divest yourself of of a
commitment to the system because it's in
the process of transforming
[Music]